so I'm gonna begin with Marjorie Hill
who's the chief executive officer of the
gay men's health crisis GMHC is as
probably most of you know is the
nation's oldest eight service
organization provides a continuum of
services to 15,000 men women and
children annually with a world-renowned
legacy of health care advocacy promoting
social justice and supporting lesbian
gay bisexual and transgender rights and
prior to her work at GMHC
dr. Hill with the assistant commissioner
for the Bureau of HIV and AIDS in the
New York City Department of Health and
Mental Hygiene and we know that New York
City has always been on the forefront of
prevention and of really promoting
Public Health in the New York City
Department of Health Marjorie was
responsible for the development of
citywide hiv/aids policy oversight for
over 400 prevention care and treatment
programs and expansion of the syringe
exchange program and my favorite fact
here Marjorie was that during your
tenure you oversaw distribution of 5
million male and female condoms annually
that's a lot of sex
and so with a firm foundation in
grassroots organizing dr. hill is
committed to a career in public service
and will share with us her thoughts and
perspective and expertise on prevention
and treatment from a structural view
Thank You Jeanette and and I actually
want to thank each and every one of you
for a couple of things while in your
research and in your programmatic life
and perhaps in your personal life you
deal with HIV and AIDS we are the
minority in this country and I'm not
talking about black people in this
instance a lot of people outside this
room think that HIV is not that big a
deal that it's over that it's so much
better and part of that is true
but if it were entirely true we wouldn't
be here all day in this room trying to
figure out how to really stem the tide
of HIV in this country in this region
and in the world so I really want to
thank you for you know doing what you do
to really combat HIV and AIDS I am a
little bit of a storyteller so I'm going
to tell a couple of stories because it's
late in the day there was a husband and
wife and the husband had developed these
strange symptoms and his wife was
getting on his case honey you should go
to the doctor you should go to the
doctor and he's he was dreadfully afraid
of going to the doctor and wouldn't go
so she kept saying honey was getting
worse it was getting worse and he said
well I'll go if you come with me so she
says fine so she goes with him to the
doctor and the doctor examines him and
he says I can't bear to hear it you know
I really need my wife for you to tell my
wife and then I will and then I she can
tell me or you can tell me or whatever
so he steps outside the wife comes in
doctor says your husband has this rare
disease rare disease then in order for
him to get better you're gonna have to
wait on him hand and foot and you're
going to have to meet his every need and
you're just gonna have to fulfill all of
his desires and if you do this he'll get
better thank you doctor really I'm glad
to hear that in she goes out and she
says husband says honey what is it she
said you're gonna die so the moral to
this story is that can-can biomedical
and behavioral approaches talk to each
other well maybe but that's not really
what I'm gonna talk about you know the
reality is that I love the title of this
conference that science equals
prevention and part of the reason why I
like it and I think maybe the reason
that motivated the organizers to name it
is it reminds us of whether we're
activists or not whether that's the
particular hat we wear banner we carry
all of us remember silence equals death
and how that really transformed and
changed and took both physical and
psychological space in our nation and in
our world well I'd like to suggest to
you this afternoon
a third mantra justice equals life the
three things I'm going to talk to you in
the time that I have and then I'll be
happy to answer questions are really
about the social determinants of health
because the reality is that whether
we're researchers whether we're program
planners or whether we do debbie's or
not the challenges of race gender class
poverty influence and affect our HIV
vention success and often dictate our
failure secondly I'm going to spend a
little bit of time focusing on one
particular challenge around those
barriers stigma while we are just about
on the eve of the 30th anniversary of
HIV and AIDS and gm8 C's 30th
anniversary things are so much better
when GMHC was formed and I'm sure when
many of the organizations were formed
here in Connecticut what we did was help
people die with dignity
we raised hell and we helped people die
we made the government pay attention not
much else I mean they weren't given much
money and you know so the attention in
some ways it took a couple of years for
it to translate into real effective
interventions and some might argue that
the government still even with the
National AIDS strategy which is very
wonderful
still has a long way to go and thirdly
I'm going to offer some examples of what
the social determinants or social
drivers are and what some effective ways
GMHC and others have done it so you know
social determinants of health are the
social economical economic political and
environmental factors that influence
one's well-being well the goal of
hiv/aids prevention has always been to
change the behavior that puts
individuals at risk to minimize those
risks to take that risk out of way and
to give the person control but the
prevention HIV prevention in particular
has always been dominated by the
individual so whether he puts on a
condom whether she carries a condom
whether or not an individual takes
personal responsibility and don't get me
wrong I think personal responsibility is
important but if we look at where 90
percent
of the HIV cases are in the world that
includes you know sometimes we talk
about global AIDS I always want to say
okay America is part of the world right
I just want yet when we look at 90
percent of where HIV cases are in the
world they occur in places where there
is significant poverty all over the
world that's true in the United States
is true and Thailand is true in South
Africa poverty is very highly associated
with HIV incidents it doesn't cause it
but very highly associated with it so
the progress of looking at the social
drivers has been limited I remember many
years ago I went to maybe my first CDC
meeting and I was like oh [ __ ] because I
say that I'm going to the CDC and I felt
like I had one message that I wanted to
say and that message was that racism was
driving HIV and I remember the director
of the division of hiv/aids prevention
looked at me and said well dr. hill what
do you want us to do in racism I thought
about that moment that was probably
about 20 years ago I thought about that
moment many times because I wish I would
have said yes now there is some justice
in continuing a fight and you know sort
of fighting a good fight and and
sticking to something you believe is
right I was part of peer-review CDC did
a peer review of all the HIV prevention
programs and dr. Fenton in his welcoming
of all of us to probably about a hundred
of us across the country um he said one
thing the CDC has not done particularly
in HIV and AIDS is owned racism owned
sexism owned home
and under my watch that's what we want
to do we want to understand dr. Fenton
said the social determinants of HIV so
what again are these social determinants
well again I talked about physical
social cultural organizational community
economic legal or policy s or aspects of
the environment
that influence this is one's life well
that's everything but you know if we're
trying to really stop HIV if we're
trying to stop the clock I think most of
us know that in this country every nine
and a half minutes there's a new HIV
case so that means since we arrived this
morning not a math major but about 40
people have zero converted today if
we're gonna make that time frame longer
we can't just give out condoms we can't
just do sista and we can't just argue
about whether or not community viral
load is an important into an important
concept it is but the reality is that
all the medication in the world is not
going to do any good if someone isn't
taking it forty-five percent of
individuals on HIV meds in New York City
are inconsistently taking their
medication have a diagnosis have a
doctor have a prescription have
insurance okay because if they're taking
meds right somebody's paying for it
forty five percent so that means all of
the great medicines and all of the
treatment as prevention language that
we're throwing is only only half of the
people are catching it okay
what are some of the structural
approaches that have been used in terms
of addressing HIV prevention the world's
health organization is really focusing
on micro financing and really focusing
on micro financing with women and that
part of the focus around that is to see
you know women have in many cultures do
not have equal standing certainly not
sexually with men even though they may
be equal and so the reality is that I
remember when my first job at GMHC I was
director of the Women's Institute and I
was going out very exciting work with
peer health educators to beauty powers
and we were giving out condoms left and
right and one of the one of the peers
came over to me and said well I'm ready
to go and I said well wait why are you
ready to go she said well they all take
in condoms but none of them are using
them so what are you talking about she
said they have pocket books full of
condoms but they don't feel empowered to
pull them out and so we started doing
you know sort of condom training and
condom demonstrations and somebody
taught me this thing about Chi King and
if you have a question I'll tell you
what that is later the people who are
laughing no but we just giving somebody
a condom when they don't have the
security the personal security is
useless giving someone all of the
Debbie's in the world and we do lots of
Debbie's we do Debbie good okay but if
someone doesn't have a roof over their
head and if their baby is hungry Debbie
is not going to help them legal actions
are up until this year the United States
had a ban a travel ban on individuals
who were HIV positive and enforced it
several countries still have travel bans
what does that mean you know in a day
and age
and scientifically we know you don't get
it through a suitcase what does it mean
to have a travel ban in this country
right now
any man whether he says he's gay or not
who has had sexual intercourse with one
man since 1973 cannot give blood can I
give blood it doesn't matter how many
shortages it doesn't matter how much he
practices safer sex doesn't it doesn't
matter if he's net it doesn't matter
it's prohibited even though the American
Red Cross says it is bad public policy
foolish why because of stigma because of
structural challenges around identity
and around who people are social
mobilization in Australia they really
grabbed hold of the challenge around MSM
and have done really phenomenal work and
the government really led the charge
around MSM gay men and really promoting
community responses and visibility of
LGBT community and a visibility of gay
men and have really managed the HIV
epidemic in a far superior way than we
have in this country up until a few
years ago the CDC was reluctant to say
the word gay now you know I understand
we're all of us understand where MSM
came from and men who have sex with men
and not everybody wants to be identified
as gay and that's that's wonderful but
in the prior administration there were
limitations around both condoms around
gay around sex in general we spent
millions of dollars in this country on
abstinence based sex education actually
I don't understand that what is
abstinence based sex education
entirely get it but we spent millions of
dollars even though we had research that
showed that it had limited effectiveness
as a solo exclusive intervention the
looking at places like Calcutta Thailand
and the Dominican Republic which now
really promote and have laws that not
just say that that sex workers should
use condoms but making those condoms
available by supporting the industry and
you know we we in America as a country
are very uncomfortable with that but
it's not stopping people from going to
sex workers so our judgments around
sexual activity sometimes heterosexual
sometimes homosexual but are not public
health pronouncements yet we let those
attitudes and values dictate our public
health interventions so so what's the
that what's the downside about these
subsidies sex these social determinants
and structural drivers well as I said
earlier it's a lot of stuff you know if
we're really going to talk about
fighting racism ending racism ending
gender disparities ending homophobia you
know that we can't quite figure out how
to get sex ed in high schools so so how
do we do this it's a very broad topic
that there are some of us who came to
the field of public health did not come
because we wanted to be activists we
came because we wanted to focus on
health outcomes and so it feels like not
quite the right fit if you will and
it's think it's very expensive I mean
you know however we were going to do it
if we found this magic bullet that was
gonna make racism go away it would be a
pretty hefty price tag so how do we do
this how do we if we accept that it's
not just about science it's not just
about treatment it's not just about
deputies it's not just about condoms how
do we address the social drivers when I
was assistant commissioner for the HIV
Bureau Tom Frieden who's now CDC was the
health commissioner and he gave me one
charge during the three years that we
work together
he said get syringe exchange in Queens
in I don't know what the issue I don't
know how it's done in Connecticut but in
New York State we've had syringe
exchange programs for probably since the
before the Dinkins administration so
about 20 years um but there had not been
a new syringe program probably for about
ten years and we looked at the the
incidence of HIV in Queens and in Staten
Island and there were through several
areas in Queens and one area in Staten
Island that had very high incidence of
substance use injection drug use in
particular and very high incidence of
HIV you don't have to be you know like a
Yale epidemiologist to figure that out
right I mean you know there's the area
however those areas in Queens none of
the groups who would be doing syringe
exchange felt like it was even worth
trying because of the tremendous
community challenge and so the
Commissioner of Health challenged the
assistant commissioner of HIV and by
challenging
go to those meetings tell me the
meetings that I have to go to meet with
the community groups meet with the
faith-based groups meet with the
politicians it took us two years but we
now have when I left when Tom and I left
there were nine new syringe programs in
Queens and I'm not as up on those
statistics in terms of incidents but
when we look at incidents of where there
are syringe exchange programs in New
York City we saw a 50% reduction in
incidents over about two or three years
so I'm assuming that that's what's
happened that is a social determinant
and intervention we have a campaign I
don't know if anyone's familiar with at
GMHC it's called I love my book
and it's a campaign that promotes
positive affirming loving interaction
between young gay men it's targeted to
gay men of color and they are pictured
holding hands hugging you know in very
sweet ways not the way that we typically
see young men of color no matter what
their sexual orientation and we
certainly don't necessarily promote two
gay guys you know conduct one kissing
the other one a cheek so we have this
whole maybe ten or so cards with these
different pictures and on the back
they're stories about who they are
and they talk about being proud of
themselves as gay men and being proud of
their community and about being in love
and about part of being proud and part
of being in love is taking care of
yourself and taking care of the person
that you love so that's our HIV
prevention intervention I'm outside the
state but I already had the conversation
so I'm going to say it if you're in New
York City it's not enough it's running
now the New York City Department of
Health just did an ad
about HIV and it's one of those some
people might remember the those your
brain on crack ads well it's the HIV
version so it says it has a young gay
guy and it says you have a hundred
percent chance or eighty nine percent
chance of getting anal cancer and you're
gonna get AIDS dementia and you know and
basically says it's better not to get it
well you don't have to spend two million
dollars to tell somebody it's better not
to get it but you should spend two
million dollars encouraging people so
we've been in a we and other
organizations have been in a discussion
with the Department of Health my friends
there about is it better to do affirming
messages or is it better to scare
tactics now the truth of the matter is
that my arguments we don't have enough
money we need to do many campaigns and
some of them might be affirming and some
of them might be scare tactics and
hopefully there'd be a lot more in
between but that didn't get much play
the third example I want to give you is
around our work force program we GMHC
has a work force program we place about
300 individuals in significant important
preferably beyond minimum wage work and
we do that by helping them a resume
writing with job skill assessment with
training we're in a court of about eight
not-for-profits we're the only HIV
organization and up until about three or
four months ago we were number one in
placement we had the lowest recidivism
rate we had the highest retention we're
running neck-and-neck with you know now
we're who's number two is it Hertz or
Avis we're number two right now but
we're working on it um but one of the
things we started the program because
about six years ago some individuals
some clients came and they said I
thought I was gonna die I didn't so get
me a job now we could get an HIV test we
can get an apartment
you know we get childcare we can get
food we get legal services but a job was
not within our purview of expertise and
so now we looked at it when we started
this workforce program what did we learn
well in addition to that there are
people who want to return to work who
can make a significant contribution to
society who you know are not you know
just who want to work and should work if
they can but that was one piece what we
found are the clients who are in work
first work work force development who
are active in that program had better
Labs have higher treatment adherence
because we get that we know how often
they go to a doctor that's part of what
we track and they report more comfort in
engaging safer sex and at first we were
surprised but then when you think about
it if you have something to look forward
to if you're feeling good about who you
are then you want to do all you can to
be as healthy as you can and you're
getting affirmed for that so workforce
development my director of workforce
talks about GED as a condom a job as a
condom you know going to college as a
condom a promotion as a condom so so
that the to sort of look at one's
capacity to earn to be a contributing
member of society we do taxes as part of
our services and the first year we did
it there was a lot of resistance around
it so we kept encouraging clients we do
it for all clients and anyone who as an
individual earns under thirty five
thousand I think for an individual and
all we needed was one person to get a
refund I think it was like $1500 and
then there was a line but what does it
mean if you don't necessarily have a lot
of discretionary income
that's another fact I just want to share
about my about my about the the clients
we see a GMHC for you to get a income
tax check what does that what does that
do to the person that you are and how
you feel about yourself in and whether
it lasts for as long as you you know
until you cash it until you spend it or
however it long it lasts that's about
how long it lasts for me in terms of you
know my being happy about paying taxes
to the federal government it does make a
difference one of the challenges around
HIV I talked about earlier is poverty
the ten thousand HIV positive
individuals that we see we obviously do
intake and we take lots of information
seventy-five percent of the clients that
GMHC
are acts or below the federal poverty
line which in New York City is I don't
even know how they could say this but
it's ten thousand dollars a year so
seventy-five percent of our clients earn
ten thousand dollars a year or less I
mean how you know New York City and I
don't know what the cost of living is in
New Haven but in New York City that
doesn't cut it probably not here either
and so those kinds of challenges
distract people from condom use distract
people from treatment adherence distract
people from you know negotiating safer
sex do we need any further proof that
structural drivers are an important
piece of the work that both researchers
both individuals who are treatment
advocates and treatment as prevention
advocates as well as individuals who are
Wed to more traditional behavioral
interventions because all across that
spectrum if we're not getting to people
if we're not keeping people if we're not
address
saying that you needs then we're not
going to be effective we provide about
ninety five thousand hot meals every
year and it's really interesting to me
because we have a lunchroom
that provides hot lunch hot lunches
Monday through Thursday and dinner on
Friday night it's a cultural traditional
thing we've done we started the meals
program about twenty three years ago at
a time when it was really about having a
social network and an opportunity for
people to have a safe space to interact
but again if you think about the figures
that I shared with you the clients who
are coming for a hot meal now some of
them it's their only hot meal and the
first of the month when many of our
clients get entitlements we probably see
about two or three hundred people in for
what's eating you know for our period of
time that we're offering a meal but at
the end of the month we can get six or
seven hundred people because you know
money's tight for us to only think about
whether they are wearing a condom or not
or even whether they're taking their
medication or not and they're hungry
where we would fall short in addition to
the social justice importance of that
many of us in this room know but
treatment uptake is better when someone
is well nourished so you have two people
who are on their meds taking your meds
regularly and consistently and
appropriately if one is getting you know
good nutrition and regular meals their
uptake is going to be better their labs
are going to be better it's crazy well
or maybe it's not so we have an
obligation in my three minutes I have
left stigma you know twenty nine and a
half years into the epidemic things are
so much better
that it's not a death sentence
we have many celebrities who talk about
HIV and AIDS you know we have magic who
talks about it and does so appropriately
now I'm glad to say but I'm a
psychologist by training and the only
clinical thing they I tease my staff
that they let me do is I run a support
group for women and the women in my
group we meet every other week in fact
we're meeting tomorrow night and they
have been living with HIV the least
amount of time is 12 years the longest
amount of time is 18 years and one week
we were doing we were ending a group and
one woman said well does anybody have an
empty aspirin bottle and thinking what a
weird request is that and so what's that
about my sisters come in I got a
disguise my meds she's all up in my
medicine cabinet because you know when
people come to your house they're
looking at medicine Kevin knows that
right if you don't I'm telling you
people looking a mess again
and so I said to her no way didn't your
sister this is a woman living with HIV
17 years she said if I told my sister I
was HIV positive my niece and nephew
could not eat at my house we have had
individuals come to GMHC a woman comes
to mind who didn't want a meal didn't
want safer sex support didn't want a
doctor didn't need an apartment she
wanted a psychiatrist not not a social
worker nada nada psych house a
psychiatrist to tell her only daughter
her 30 year old daughter who had just
had a baby that it was okay for her to
hold her only grandchild
you know we can do better we have to do
better
so silence equal death
silence equal science equals change and
justice equals life thank you very much
dr. Stephen Morin is a psychologist as
well that makes three of us up here from
the NAT from that nasty science he is a
professor of medicine and chief of the
division of prevention science in the
Department of Medicine at UCSF he is the
director of the Center for AIDS
prevention studies and the AIDS Policy
Research Center dr. Morin is also
associate director of the UCSF Center
for AIDS research or the CFR he holds
the Walter gray endowed chair and
hiv/aids science at at the AIDS Research
Institute and for a decade prior from
1987 to 1997
dr. Morin hung out down in Washington DC
where he was the principal legislative
assistant to representative Nancy Pelosi
and also worked for the Labor HHS
education Appropriations Subcommittee
and so while in Washington Stephen
played a part in almost every AIDS
related policy at the federal level
Steve has also served as co-chair of the
HIV prevention trials network or the HP
TN community working group his research
on HIV prevention surveillance
disparities and more is noted for its
scientific excellence and scope and also
its impact locally nationally and
globally please join me in welcoming dr.
Stephen Morin
thank you so much of course it's hard to
follow Marjorie but I want to commend
her for her comments and I wanted since
you got a story I I'll tell a story to
this MSM thing can be a problem I was
doing a letter last week a letter for a
colleague and I was endorsing her grant
proposal and I was saying she had these
large cohorts she was following inches
doing excellent job on on men who have
sex with men but I dropped the in on the
end of men so it read we're doing a
large study on men who had sex with me
and he held this large cohort I went on
to say never mind
back to the topic you know No
the topic today is treatment as
prevention to go back to my days on
Capitol Hill particularly the six years
with the Appropriations Committee this
was not the concept we heard much of
what we heard a lot about was treatment
versus prevention which were you going
to fund which was a higher priority what
is really interesting in today's
discussion is that we're talking about
the concept of treatment as prevention
and the way in which they can there's
synergy the other debate that were maybe
going to have is about how much of this
is behavioral and how much of this is
biomedical so why don't we start on that
I don't need to review the with you
you've heard today a lot about the
National hiv/aids strategy and
particularly the goal of reducing new
infections some of this concept of
treatment is prevention goat went to a
modeling paper out of South Africa that
really took the thesis can we treat our
way out of the epidemic in other words
if we got maximum number of people in
treatment we suppress their viral load
they were no longer infectious how long
it would it take to get rid of the
damnit well that's wildly optimistic but
it Modelling the United States does
suggest that in fact if you took a test
and treat approach you could
significantly reduce the number of new
infections however advocates like
Marjorie made all their points and
they've come up with a term testing
linkage to linkage to care plus
treatment to recognize the need of all
these support services like housing and
nutrition and all the like and
old-fashioned social work that must be
accompanied with any approach that
attempts to do a test and treat strategy
they also focus on the need for this to
be voluntary and that no one should be
compulsory tested or treated I'm going
to move a bit to implementation science
implementation science is a process
where you go through and you you decide
you want to implement something like a
TLC plus strategy what are the problems
where are the gaps in being able to
deliver the product and you'll see here
in this green there are four major
problem areas the first is that up to 21
percent of the people in the US are
undiagnosed when the second green bubble
when they do get diagnosed it's late and
the third green bubble is that they are
often not linked to care post diagnosis
and then the third and really
unrecognized problem is the extent that
one-third of people who know they have
HIV are not in care so these three gaps
become the research agenda and what's
interesting about them is that are not
necessarily a biomedical research agenda
they're almost all social behavioral and
policy research
objectives so let me take you through
some of these one by one first challenge
identifying people who are undiagnosed
we know we can do but haven't been doing
social marketing campaigns on the
importance of knowing one's status we
could implement the I know Paul Clara's
been working on the barriers to
implementing routine testing as
recommended by the CDC but there are
other strategies as well we do have the
CDC recommendations that by and large
they have not been implemented the way
they were intended this is a study we
conducted at six community health
centers with the National Association of
community health centers in Alabama
South Carolina and Mississippi where
you'd expect to find a lot of infections
but of the people seeing there are
nearly 60,000 people seen when these
people were committed to doing routine
testing only 28% of people who seen were
offered the test and of those only 69
percent accepted and when all is done
only 14 were linked to care in fact
there were 19 false positives more than
there were true positives so it's not
just implementing routine testing you
have to choose where you're going to
find the maximum load of new infections
so that you can be cost efficient and
good places are emergency departments
and STD clinics and other places where
you can expect to find coincident HIV
infection we looked recently at three
such emergency departments in the
poorest neighborhoods in the San
Francisco Bay Area mostly in Oakland and
what we found is that indeed the
programs differed wildly the definition
of routine was very different but we did
find some successful programs were peep
at the time of notification people were
linked at that
to care so there are models out there
that could be replicated second area for
research identifying individuals earlier
in their infection so how do you do that
we have a large trial in Africa where
we're doing community mobilization and
testing and we have tested large numbers
of proportions of communities and
greatly increased by more than fourfold
the detection of cases so you can do it
with a careful mobile mobilization you
can do such things as text messaging and
small incentives for regular interval
testing we're talking about frequency of
testing here and community level
interventions so that you make frequent
testing normative particularly
particularly with gay men who are using
Cir assorting strategies community
mobilization itself comes from diffusion
of innovation this is the cell phone few
people have it other people like it
thought it about becomes normative to
have a cell phone well we use the same
basic theory to make it normative to
know your HIV status or to test it at
intervals of six three or six months so
these become you go in you work with the
communities you involve community
leaders almost all of these groups are
motivated by larger community goals and
you have to work these strategies in
there but the goal is through all of
this mobilization is to increase
detection and linkage to care a good
example is the campaign that's been up
and operating for a few years in
Washington DC they've looked at
providers for provider initiated testing
they've been working in the jail's
they've been doing advertising and they
have been able to increase from 2004 to
2008 almost four-fold increase
in testing and a 17% increase in new
newly diagnosed cases being identified
and if you see these chart you'll see
that each year the mean cd4 goes up
indicating that are getting people
earlier and earlier in their infections
so these campaigns can work the other
part about early detection is the really
early detection and this is the work on
acute infection you'll see in the first
three to four weeks of infection people
are highly infectious and it's important
to try to capture as many of those
people as possible so we need better
testing technology to find these
although we probably the biggest yield
is going to come from campaigns of
providers where the providers look to
for the symptoms if someone comes in
after a high-risk exposure and is
reporting fever at night those sorts of
things should trigger testing for both
antibodies and antigen campaigns among
high-risk individuals these are
high-risk negatives don't screw with the
flu get carefully evaluated every time
you have a temperature or it looks like
the flu we need to change our counseling
protocols so that when people are
detected during the acute phase they are
told that they are more infectious and
that they have to be much more careful
careful about transmitting to others and
we have to develop a public health
system that is able to respond quickly
so that the tests don't sit in
laboratories this is just a slide on one
of our studies and it's actually a study
we did with the Yale you'll see these
graphs these are people who were acutely
infected and what happened before they
were diagnosed you'll see the blue is
positive partners the purple is negative
partners in the green is unknown so they
had a
mostly negative and unknown partners at
the two time intervals we interviewed
them post diagnosis or disclosure of
their HIV you'll see that the partners
are almost all HIV infected so the
notification in and of itself led to
zero sorting and greatly reduced the
probability of transmission to others I
was going to sing the advantages of
rapid technology that's coming out
although this particular product bombed
at the CROI meeting a couple weeks ago
but there are other ones out there that
don't think of this one too seriously
but the fourth-generation CIA will be
able to address many of these issues the
next part is promoting not just testing
people who've never been tested before
but how frequently should people test so
this is promoting regularly testing
among people who are at very increased
risk because of their behavioral profile
and what we found is that people will
respond and test at three month
intervals if there's some incentive and
if you just text them to tell them come
in at a purpose if ik time they think
it's a great idea particularly if you
explain it in terms of the benefits to
them and the risks of acute infection so
in the next area and this is this is
different than most study sections see
they you know we've spent so much time
with studies that really look at condom
promotion or reducing number of partners
or that sit or go studies on linkage to
care have not been great but it is a
very important issue in our surveillance
systems people who have been not been
seen in the last six months have average
viral loads twice those of people who
have been seen in care in the last six
months so treatment the viral load on
the individual level is extremely
important and you'll see it's important
on the
level as well various strategies
delinked people to care this was a CDC
study case management it worked fairly
well we have much better we have much
better interventions in the pipeline now
at some of these navigator not going to
go into detail but these come out of the
cancer literature where when you're
diagnosed you get a patient navigator
who goes to appointments with you tells
you what to expect all of that they're
culturally matched and we've been able
to get over ninety percent people linked
within a month period out of our
programs at the San Francisco General
Hospital so were very optimistic that
these adapt this came largely out of the
Boston group in the Fenway clinic but
there's a lot of potential there for
linkage again careful studies have to be
done and they haven't retention in care
is even more important if you look at
quarters and care and adjusted R as
hazard ratio of death you'll see that
the the differences are quite enormous
that you really are at great risk of
death this is a death endpoint if not
retained in care so what do we do to
retain people in care almost nothing so
here here's this is ripe for research
what works and retaining people in care
you know that they like to see the same
person at the front desk they like to
see a match to provide with their things
that could be done linkage and retention
are very distinct and in engagement in
care over a long term is the primary
predictor of health outcomes so a
research in this area is very important
what we do know is that substance abuse
mental health housing all of the things
Marjorie talked about our primary
predictors of
attention and that we could do a much
better job than we're currently doing so
we have as researchers problems even in
the definition of what what is retention
we have no control trials in the
literature it's we don't have a
literature that's actually linked to the
content of the visit so there's much
room for improvement all we have is a
couple retrospective studies from VA
hospitals so for people wanting exciting
areas of new research which are
primarily behavioral although they're
about retention in care this is a great
area to focus well once you get people
in care the issue is maintaining viral
suppression as a way to improve health
outcomes as many of you know the
treatment guidelines have been changed
so that treatment is recommended for cd4
cells under 500 but San Francisco and
half of the guidelines committee now
endorsed treatment for everybody as soon
as they are diagnosed with HIV the
advantages is that you treat it as an
inflammatory process and you can get
better and health outcomes at an
individual level of course this is the
individuals choice so it's only a
discussion with the individual and they
make an informed decision in
consultation with their providers there
are potential downsides to it but those
all have to be dealt with in terms of
the risk and benefit involved one of the
benefits is reduced transmission risk to
others the modeling we've done in San
Francisco suggests if you go with
treatment guidelines of the CD for under
500 you can basically reduce the number
of new infections the net result would
be about by 33% in 2029 but if you treat
everybody you see that goes to fifty
five percent and if you test people at
these
month intervals and treat everyone you
could reduce by as much as 81% so the
ability to have major impact on reducing
the number of new cases is there how do
you improve health outcomes among those
in care adherence is essential we know
from a body of research that's well
studied we know the interventions that
work
we just need to implement them we know
that substance abuse is high in this
patient population we know it is one of
the reasons people do not link or retain
and care we can screen for it in waiting
rooms we can refer for treatment we can
do much better particularly with
electronic medical records where you can
do the screening and do the prompts and
while you're at it you can do prevention
with positives the very important can be
done a number of different ways we have
all of these interventions that have
been proven in randomised trials however
without any getting into details paper
we're just publishing right now provider
based interventions are the shortest and
are by far the most cost effective and
indeed they're they're very simple to do
screening is done in the waiting room a
message is sent to the provider it's
clipped on the chart it takes it takes
on average about a minute and a half
okay
so various people are saying okay these
things are all very important how do you
put them all together and there are a
number of studies like this the HIV
prevention trials Network has a TLC plus
protocol they're doing in DC and in the
Bronx and you'll see the study
components are very much about the five
issues I just talked about so if there's
a pretty good agreement on what this
strategy should look like you can add
all kinds of optimum optional
interventions
with it the other one you heard a bit
about from Judy arbok this morning is
the 12 city project that was an issue is
initiated by the CDC they're doing an
attempt to implement or at least plan to
implement the National AIDS strategy in
these twelve metropolitan areas some of
our HIV prevention science centers and
CFR's are involved in this project as
well one that's I don't have a slide on
but hearses about to initiate a project
of replicating this in eight states so
eight states will be selected to
implement the National hiv/aids strategy
and that will be evaluated in that
context you know you can just see what
the goals very much what I've been
talking about are the goals of the CDC
project and we are proud to be a member
of a five group five Center
collaborative with Yale Columbia Medical
College of Wisconsin and UCLA that are
looking at very much the same issues
trying to assess the effectiveness of
multi-level interventions primarily with
community viral load as them as an
outcome as a because it is a good marker
for diagnose new HIV cases so these are
some of what's in the process now I'm
going to courageously talk a bit about
San Francisco and what's happening there
San Francisco yeah San Francisco is a
population about 800,000 but we have
eighteen thousand five hundred living
with HIV so we have very high prevalence
and MSM who are not IDU we have a
prevalence of 23% of the MSM who are IDU
it's 47% so we got a lot of HIV and over
90% of it is in
MSM MSM IDU so here's a couple questions
behavioural or biological this is
looking at trends over the last five
years in unprotected anal intercourse so
you see it's gone from forty two percent
to thirty three percent and got hmong
that's the Green Line that's the
negatives is that going to produce a
decrease in incidence or not enough and
among the positives who can transmit
you'll see it's gone from fifty seven to
sixty it's actually gone up so is that
enough behavior change to bring down
incidents number of partners flap no
difference this looks at you know this
looks at something very different though
this looks at unprotected anal
intercourse in the last six months with
a potentially discordant partner so this
is serous sorting and if you look at the
negatives the Green Line we've got an
awful lot of thorough sorting because
all that unprotected sex is part of a
Sarah sorting strategy so that many
people think if you have this serous
sorting strategy been controversial very
controversial does it work are we going
to get reduced incidents because we have
been doing this for five years yes no is
it good enough it's behavioral
and then substance abuse you'll see
substance abuse has been fairly flat but
there's been this lot bottom line is
methamphetamine which has been our
biggest risk factor among the substances
and it's gone from 12 percent to 8
percent way high but still some
improvement is that enough to bring down
incidence probably getting a lot of
shaking heads it's probably
so those are kind of some of the
behaviors if you were just looking at
this as behavior would you expect
incidents to go up or down okay how
about some more information over from
2004 to 2008 among MSM tested in the
last 12 months went from 65 to 71 so it
went up 6% that's good is that going to
help
among those tested in the last six
months it really went up by 12% this is
because people who choose a sir sorting
strategy have to test at least six every
six months to be credible to their
partners so if you have a thorough
sorting strategy you get more frequent
testing does that reduce incidents the
number of people or who are HIV positive
who don't know their status declined
declined quite significantly below the
national average down to about 17
percent should that help that's part of
the National AIDS strategy does that
help reduce incidence all right and then
we get into these other things that are
really part of testing treat engaged in
care went from 71% to 78 that means that
they're showing up regularly for
appointments we have a universal access
program in San Francisco called San
Francisco cares
we have universal access to a RV's so
these are really surprising number is
going from 74 to 90% of people on ARVs
and probably the most impressive going
from 52 to 72 an increase of 20% into
people living in San Francisco who are
virally suppressed should that change
incidence yes or no is it going to go up
or is it gonna go down
it's gone down it's gone down from 798
cases to 434 cases a year so can you get
25% or more reduction in incident cases
yes now you have to now you have to tell
me whether that was behavioral or
biomechanical what's that behavioral or
was that biomechanical all of the above
the point is that you can't in these
combination approach approaches to
prevention and multi-level interventions
much of which were driven by the
community and were not planned I might
add you cannot separate out which is
which so that the only way to really
have these kinds of combination
Prevention's with these significant
outcomes is that you do all this at once
and you try to do a better job at each
single point of potential intervention
and with that I think there's
considerable hope that these principles
from the National hiv/aids strategy can
be implemented although ARVs are clearly
a biomedical intervention there are so
many of these behavioral components that
make it happen that it can truly be
described as a joint behavioral and
biomedical approach do you get back to
your question is can these two
approaches successively converge and I'd
say yes then that they already have and
that the lessons learned here couldn't
be transferred to almost any local
jurisdiction gonna be measurement issues
that are going to be funding issues
there's going to be community
preparedness issues there
to be all of that to sort through thank
you